three o'clock will be facing 3:30 got to
get lunch in there I like myself
tortured yeah sorry survival
as a reminder today's event has been set
up to adhere to social distancing
guidelines as outlined by health experts
thank you
you
good afternoon I am here today to talk
about infrastructure and jobs on clean
energy future but I have to start by
speaking about what millions Americans
know when they wake up every morning
with worry anxiety and fear we're still
a country in crisis the pandemic is
affected more than 3 million Americans
it has cost more than 135 thousand lives
in climbing and it shows no signs of
slowing down in just the last few days
19 states 19 states reported record
cases including Florida which saw more
than 15,000 new cases in a single day
hospitalizations and deaths too the most
concerning indicators of Trump's failed
response are already unacceptably high
and they are rising it's got bad enough
that even Donald Trump finally decided
to wear a mask in public I'm glad he
made the shift mr. president is not
enough we won't be able to turn the
corner and get the American people back
to work safely without presidential
leadership mr. president
open everything now isn't a strategy for
success is barely a slogan quit pushing
the false choice between protecting our
health and protecting our economy all it
does is endanger our recovery on both
fronts mr. president please listen to
your public health experts instead of
denigrating them do your job mr.
president because if we can't deal with
the public health crisis we can't deal
with the economic crisis or deal with
almost 18 million Americans who are out
of work and the incredible pain
inflicted on small businesses and
communities of color
we can't deal with a climate crisis to
cost us and cast us into an even darker
and more permanent shadow who would loom
over the country in the world for a long
time we won't be able to do what
Americans have always done come back
stronger than ever before with the grit
toughness and resilience that
characterizes who we are that's what I
want to talk about today last week I
shared the outlines of my plan to build
back better a ball plan to build an
economy of the future not an economy of
the past and the first plank of that
plan rejects the defeatist view that
automation and globalization mean we
can't ensure our future is made in
America with American paying good-paying
union jobs here at home making it in
America we clearly can today I'm here in
Wilmington to talk about a second plank
how we could create millions of
high-paying union jobs by building a
modern infrastructure and a clean energy
future these are the most critical
investments we can make for the
long-term health and vitality of both
the American economy and the physical
health and safety of the American people
even if we weren't facing a pandemic and
an economic crisis we should be making
these investments anyway one in five
miles of our highways are still in quote
poor condition according to the American
engineers 10 thousands actually tens of
thousands the bridges are in disrepair
and some of the verge of collapse
presenting a clear and present danger to
people's lives tens of millions of
Americans lack access to high-speed
broadband to get our people to work on
our kids at school safely to get our
kids to market swiftly to power a clean
energy revolution in this country we
need to modernize the
America's infrastructure despite this
overwhelming need this president and a
Republican Congress have simply failed
to act there's no other way of saying it
to continue to break the promises they
made to the American people
Donald Trump promised a big
infrastructure bill when he raided in
2016 he promised it again in 2017 and
then in 2018 and again in 2019 and now
he's promising one again seems like
every few weeks when he needs a
distraction from the latest charges of
corruption and his staff or the
conviction of high-ranking members of
administration and political apparatus
the White House announces quote its
infrastructure week how many times
you've heard him say that but he's never
delivered it's never really even tried
well I know how to get it done in 2009
President Obama and I inherited an
economy and freefall and we prevented
another Great Depression we enact the
largest infrastructure plan since
President Eisenhower's interstate
highway system not only creating
good-paying jobs but improving the
safety and security of people on our
roads we made the largest investment in
clean energy in history of the United
States of America ninety billion dollars
and it put us on a path toward a
thriving clean energy economy
powering new economy economic growth and
reducing energy cost here we are now
with an economy in crisis but with an
incredible opportunity and not just the
bill back to where we were before but
better stronger more resilient and more
prepared for the challenges that lie
ahead and there's no more consequential
challenge that we must
in the next decade and the onrushing
climate crisis left unchecked it is
literally an existential threat to the
health of our planet and to our very
survival that's not up for dispute mr.
president when Donald Trump thinks about
climate change the only word he can
muster is hoax when I think about
climate change the world I think of as
jobs good pain Union jobs that have put
Americans to work Americans to work
making the air cleaner for our kids to
breathe restoring our crumbling roads
and bridges and ports making it faster
cheaper and cleaner to transport
american-made goods all across the
country and around the world jobs jobs
to bill and install a network of 500,000
charging stations along our existing and
new highways we would build across this
country which not I will help America an
American automobile industry lead the
world of manufacturing with electric
vehicles will also save Americans
billions of dollars over time in the
cost of gasoline for their vehicles jobs
that lay the lines for the second great
railroad revolution which will not only
slash pollution most last commute times
and it opened up investment in areas
connected to metropolitan centers for
the first time when Donald Trump thinks
about renewable energy he sees windmills
somehow causing cancer when I think
about these windmills I see American
manufacturing American workers racing to
dominate the global market
I see the steel that will be needed for
those windmill platforms towers and
ladders that can be made in small
manufacturers like the McGregor
industries I was up in Scranton last
week I see the Union trained and
certified men and women will manufacture
and install at all I see the port's that
will come back to life the longshoremen
the shipbuilders the
Unity's they support when Donald Trump
talks about improving efficiency by
retrofitting lighting systems only with
LED bulbs remember what he said he said
he doesn't like LED because quote the
lights no good I always look orange end
of quote the lights no good I always
look orange when I think about Energy
retrofitting for lighting
I see the incredible projects like the
one right here in the chase Center I see
small businesses like preferred electric
that design and install award-winning
energy conservation measures they reduce
consumption of electricity and save
businesses hundreds of thousands of
dollars in energy costs per year I see
master electricians and union workers
went through Union apprenticeships who
start off good wages and quality
benefits that only grow from there these
investments are win-win-win for this
country creating jobs cutting energy
cost protecting our climate that's why
today I'm releasing my plan to mobilize
millions of jobs by building sustainable
infrastructure and and and an equitable
clean energy future - my first four
years we're going to give four million
buildings all across this country the
same energy makeover that you get here
at chase a chase Center it's going to
create at least 1 million jobs in
construction engineering and
manufacturing in order to get it done
it's going to make places the places
where we work we live we learn healthier
improving indoor air quality and water
quality it's going to save tens of
billions of dollars in energy cost over
time that's all real we're not just
going to focus on commercial spaces
though we're gonna give direct support
tell families do the same thing for
their homes
or an offer cash rebates and low-cost
financing to upgrade energy and
efficient appliances and windows
improvements that will cut their monthly
energy bills and overtime save them
thousands of dollars a year I think
we're gonna make a major investment to
build 1.5 million new energy-efficient
homes and public housing units will
benefit from communities all the
communities three times over by
alleviating affordable housing crisis by
increasing energy efficiency and by
reducing the racial wealth gap linked to
homeownership last week I talked about
using the purchasing power of the
federal government to reinvigorate
domestic manufacturing that's what we're
gonna do with the American automobile
industry as well the United States owns
and maintains an enormous fleet of
vehicles and we're going to convert
these government fleets to electric
vehicles made and sourced right here in
the United States of America but the
government providing the demand and the
grants to retool factories that are
struggling to compete the US auto
industry and as deep banks of suppliers
will step up expanding capacity of the
United States not China leads the world
and clean vehicle production we're gonna
make it easier for American consumers to
switch to electric vehicles as well not
only by building 500,000 charging
stations but by offering rebates and
incentives to swap older fuel-efficient
vehicles for a new clean made in America
vehicles saving hundreds of billions of
barrels millions of barrels of oil on an
annual basis
together this will mean 1 million new
good-paying jobs in the automobile
industry its supply chain and the
associated infrastructure needed to get
it done we also know that transforming
the American
ethical sector to produce power without
producing carbon pollution and
electrifying an increased share of our
economy will be the greatest spurring of
job creation and economic
competitiveness in the 21st century
that's why we're going to achieve a
carbon pollution free electric sector by
the year 2035 need to get to work on it
right away
we'll need the scientists of the
National Labs the land great
universities HBCUs to improve and
innovate technologies needed to generate
store and transmit this clean energy we
need the engineers to design them the
workers to manufacture them we need iron
workers welders to install them will
become the world's largest exporter of
these technologies creating even more
jobs we know how to do this
our administration rescued the auto
industry and helped to retool made solar
energy the same cost as traditional
energy weatherize more than a million
homes and we'll do it again but this
time bigger and faster and smarter and
as we do this work we need to be mindful
of the historical wrongs and the damage
that American industries have done in
the 20th century inflicting
environmental harm and the poor in
vulnerable communities so often black
and brown and Native American
communities flew their polluted water
toxins raining down from communities
that bore environmental and health
burdens but shared none of the profits
growing up breathing that and every day
it's poisoned it's partly why there's
such incredible rates of childhood
asthma in black and brown communities
why black Americans are almost three
times more likely to die of asthma
related causes in white Americans it's
cancer alley in st. James Parish in
Louisiana
that's the cancer causing clusters along
Route nine right here in Delaware
and that's why today I'm also releasing
the state of the environment justice
policies that build on my existing plan
this is an area of incredible
opportunity for economic growth for our
country but we have to make sure that
the first people will benefit from this
or the people who were most basically
hurt by it historically in the last
century by the structural disparities
that exist I'm setting a goal to make
sure that these frontline and fenceline
communities whether in rural places or
center cities receive 40 percent of the
benefit from the investments were making
in housing and pollution reduction and
workforce development and transportation
across the board
we're also going to create jobs for
people by cleaning up the environmental
hazards that have now been abandoned you
saw the first the front page of The
Times two days ago all these places that
are going bankrupt except for the
benefit that's growing millions and
millions of dollars going to the CEOs
more than a quarter million jobs right
away to do things like plugging millions
of abandoned oil and gas wells that
exist all across the country posing
daily threats to the health and safety
of our communities we're going to hold
accountable those CEOs and corporations
the benefit from decades of subsidies
then just walked away from their
responsibilities to these communities
leaving the wells to leak pollutants to
continue to spew greenhouse gases
flowing into the air in the water and
all they're going to repeal those
subsidies we're going to go after those
golden parachutes the CEOs gave
themselves before declaring bankruptcy
to make sure the workers received the
benefits and retirement they were
promised let's create new markets for
our family farmers and our ranchers a
new modern-day
civilian climate court kill our public
lands
to make us less vulnerable to wildfires
and floods look these aren't
pie-in-the-sky dreams
these are actionable policies then we
can get to work on right away we can
live up to our responsibilities meet the
challenges of a world at risk of a
climate catastrophe build more climate
resilient communities put millions of
skilled workers on the job and make life
markedly better and safer for the
American people all at once and benefit
the world on the process the alternative
continue to ignore the facts deny
reality focus only on technology the
last century instead of inventing the
technologies that will define this
century just plain an American not to
this is all the Donald Trump and
Republicans offer backward looking
policies that will harm the environment
make communities less healthy hold back
economic promise all other countries
race ahead it's a mindset that doesn't
have any faith the capacity of the
American people to compete to innovate
and to win it's never been a good bet to
bet against the American people and when
you do will exact a deadly cost I know
better I know you do as well I know what
the American people are capable of I
know what American workers can
accomplish when given the room to run I
know the climate change is a challenge
that's going to define our American
future
I know meeting the challenge will be a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to jolt
new life into our economy strengthen our
global leadership protect our planet for
future generations the five the honor of
being elected president we're not just
going to tinker around the edges we're
going to make historic investments that
will seize the opportunity to meet this
moment in history we're going to get to
work to deliver results right away on
we're gonna reverse Trump's rollbacks of
100 public health and environmental
rules and then forge a path to greater
ambition we're gonna get back into the
Paris agreement back into the business
of leading the world we're gonna lock in
progress that no future president can
roll back or undercut to take us
backward again science requires a
timetable for measuring progress on
climate that isn't three decades or even
two science tells us we have nine years
before the damage is irreversible
so my timetable results is in my first
four years as president the jobs that
will create the investments will make
and the irreversible steps will take to
mitigate and adapt to the climate change
and put our nation on the road to Net
Zero emissions no later than 2015 so
let's not waste any more time let's get
to work now now Thank You president time
for a few questions
did you get those questions
is that it there's not like an encore
kind of thing where they're gonna like
surprises if we just sit in silence
[Laughter]
one two
one two
one two